hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach is actually have some
interesting news I went to the SCP game
recently of the game website recently
and I saw they have a new splash screen
now using meta [ __ ] is in there okay
here we go anyway so they have a new
splash screen on their main website that
says the gate will open October 31st
which is very interesting I'm actually
very excited about that particular fact
because that means that very soon not
again
oh god of what the hell what happened
whoa whoa whoa
why don't ever the what how did I die
how did I die you have got to be close
my eyes for a second how did I die
hey either way it means that there's
either gonna be a new update -
containment breach or a whole new thing
coming out on the 31st there every given
that there we go here we go oh go go go
looking at the entire time come on I'm
almost done with this I realize what I
have to do is I have to find the tunnel
first if when I find the tunnel if I go
into the tunnel then radical Larry is
gonna find me and I don't need to find
him and either way I got to find the
tunnel anyway
what da hell I know you're in that
corner
anyway so if I can find the tunnel and
that he will come to me and I don't need
to go anywhere near him oh crap which
way did I go remember I don't remember I
don't remember it's been a while how did
you get down at Dow how I was I was what
I didn't I didn't do it I I don't know I
think I went down that way before
already though I mean some graphical
errors in here in case you forgot it
what I needed
did you go ready to go ha ha
guys persistent you must know that I'm
getting what be the way second I got a
text okay I think I went down there
before I'm not sure all the doors are
open all the doors are open everywhere
damn and I I hope it's not I hope it's
not kind of to the point where you know
maybe I can't get to the thing maybe I
can't get to it because you know okay so
this is the machine cuz maybe this
particular map spawn doesn't have it I
don't know crap I haven't been I know
I've already been in here
I need to be thorough at least the
reason I'm wearing the gas mask is
because it's super powered and makes me
run okay obviously there's nothing in
there that I need so I have been down
here but that other area must be where I
came from and the way I'll need to down
it again one of these safes doesn't make
me full floor ah what a radical Larry oh
you want some just Riya we're yeah we're
yet bro huh huh where I don't see him
right okay all right then
false alarm
okay is he gonna pop up and kill me
again
good I thought gosh Jim jiminy Christmas
it's dark in here
I cuz I'm wearing this mask oh I know I
know what's going on guys this
particular map Swann doesn't have an
elevator
golly oh man oh that's such a shame for
sure it was gonna happen guys God right
there I thought I had this fudge big
fudge uh well no time no use wasting
time kid's gonna be a tempt one attempt
at what disabling trowel and here we go
all right sorry guys I mean I thought
that was the one I really thought I had
that man all right
so close I had everything in place and
there there's no elevator isn't that
lovely
I guess that's just the way it goes
gasps most the thing there were two of
these always in a row
oh hi of the hallways in a row I'm not
novel II right off the bat okay you want
to dance mother fudger you want to dance
ah I'd dance good likeness
I dance good I am good dance person not
here thank you
aha
it's not gonna wait this is what is why
is that red I was that red must trigger
the lighting that nots ready to damnit a
level one level ones don't do me any
good
Oh even though another one can open a
door I guess a must what would be the
point so there's nothing behind me I
know that I never need to go back okay I
know what's in this room I don't even
need to go in there it's him hi okay
dammit another one of these
just yet
aren't you just a lovely brightly lit
room Oh fantastical at least there's a
lot of potential for you no room spawns
in our back but I really really need to
find radical Aries
I really need to get before radical Airy
I don't have a key card for these I need
a level to bare minimum to get into the
machine room I need a level two what is
this
now this different I don't recall seeing
this ever I got a stop back stop it stop
it the walls owes green slime heard that
one and this map spawn is big so much
too big guy handle man I'm just going in
also to dr. harp wait a minute what is
this
access code access code no way
this is doctor gears dr. Maynard I've
never seen any of these I've really I've
never seen any of these I'll get a level
2 card in here holy crap this is
completely new I better hold on to this
save and that means this save is not
gonna drop me through the floor please
don't drop me through the floor oh
there's like card in yours in there no
not in this one no radio though hang on
I've got too many batteries okay I've
been told to keep this on three walk
through the rums
Oh what the hell what the hell
uh hi hey buddy how are you doing you're
one of the Class D personnel what why
are you why are you sleepy why can't I
sleep I'm gonna hold that off for a
second crap these are places I've never
seen electrical Center I've never seen
the electrical Center please let my
little one open this yes I finally whoa
seriously this is blowing my mind right
now there's totally new stuff in this
episode I thought I've seen everything
what hell is this place
I got a bad feeling about this
primary lighting ah remote door control
aw
why are these these are all there we go
wait one
growl on man if you guys know what's
going on here I really like you guys to
let me know in the comments below
because I'm gonna really really really
try to hold on to the save and really
hope I don't fall through the floor at
any time okay
so primary lighting so this was on so
let me flip it off just a change I have
my honestly having no idea what this is
all about
I am completely Wow I go there I go
through the floor what good thing though
isn't the same please let this work
please let this work please this is such
a great save this is such a great map
seed good thing it's on record if you
guys got the record of the map seed oh
thank god oh okay don't sprint up those
stairs cuz it's kind of don't sprint
down those stairs cuz I that's what sent
me through the floor
okay so lights are gonna go off now
oh there we on that off I don't know
what that does but give it a try okay
don't fall through the floor don't fall
through the floor okay we're good
good you stuck the landing good job
there buddy
aha yes oh this is absolutely perfect
this is radical Larry's room I opened
the door from the outside that means if
he ports me in there I can get out so
long as I have a keycard I don't have
the right key card I'm still in trouble
I can't let him get me or at least I
can't let him get me while he's and pour
me there so okay gonna save please don't
let me fall through the floor after that
please don't let me fall through the
floor I asked one thing and one thing
only what is that excuse me I want to
know about these these doctors offices
if you guys know what this is all about
- please let me know but I am all out of
time so I'm really looking forward to
the next episode this should be this is
proving very interesting and I'm pretty
excited about so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotations for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye